[Music]
I bought my office crusher Rose not
knowing she had two weeks off work I
left it in my locker and it looked good
enough to give her when she came back
the head fell off as I hand it to her
I got food poisoning from a burrito bowl
at my boyfriend's house then his heat
went out and it was one of the coldest
days of the year I had to wear my winter
coat in his bed covered in three
blankets while trying not to my pants at
least he was very nice about it in high
school we used to give each other
carnations as Valentines everyone in our
school got flowers from friends were
special someone's except for me for
years and not a single flower last
Valentine's Day my long-distance
boyfriend and I got into a fight I do
write to say sorry by sending him a
heart-shaped pizza from Pizza Hut and 30
minutes later I got a call saying he
refused the delivery when she asked me
what I wanted to do with it I started
crying and told her to eat it my
long-distance internet boyfriend of
several years surprised me at my college
dorm on February 13th it was the first
time we met in person but when I invited
him to stay the night he revealed he was
just stopping through Illinois on his
way to New York for he was moving to
live with his actual girlfriend I had to
go for a colonoscopy on Valentine's Day
romantic as
[Music]
[Music]